[Music]
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new house of the dragon game of
thrones video all about the big first
look that they just dropped there's a
really huge episode that they've been
filming so i'll explain what's going on
there's a bunch of easter eggs it's a
really cool battle and it's probably
gonna be their big black water level
event for the season if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i will be doing full
episode videos for house of the dragon
just like i did for the game of thrones
main series most of you probably found
my channel during game of thrones at
some point but the actual battle that
they're filming looks like it's going to
be earlier in the timeline the war for
the stepstones which is sort of a
precursor for this super bloody battle
that happens later during the actual
dance of the dragons called the battle
of the gullet so i'll talk both about
the war for the stepstones and the
battle of the gullit because it
basically involves a lot of the same
people but a lot of these scenes
confirmed that they're also going to be
doing way more flashbacks during the
house of the dragon prequel series than
they ever did during the game of thrones
main series for whatever reason dan and
dave just really hated the idea of
flashbacks early on in the series but
they kind of relented in later seasons
when we started to get the ned star
tower of joy baby jon snow flashbacks
now dan and dave don't have anything to
do with the brand new house of the
dragon prequel series so it sounds like
the people who are doing house of the
dragon just aren't as opposed to doing
flashbacks also doing a lot more
flashbacks explains how they're gonna
get five to seven seasons out of a
conflict out of a civil war that only
lasted for a couple years but when i say
the battle that we see in all these
scenes here is probably going to be
their big black water level event
obviously every year game of thrones
always had like a big wtf episode like a
red wedding or a hard home or a black
water for instance black water during
season two but the war for the
stepstones took place down in the
southern area of the narrow sea against
the triarchy which is the combined
forces of the free cities of essos mir
lis and tyrosh it started when damon
targaryen furious at not being named the
next heir by his older brother viserys
targaryen tried to carve out his own
kingdom down here in this area so he
invaded on his dragon caraxies and faced
the forces of the triarchy who then used
that experience to learn to fight him
and fight dragons on their ships much
later in the timeline during the battle
of the gullet which we'll talk about in
a second because it bears a lot of
similarities to battles during the game
of thrones main series but you see him
running around here with his sword dark
sister his valyrian blade the one that
everyone thought that mira reed might
have taken in the later seasons of the
main game of thrones series because the
last known owner of the sword was
brendan rivers aka the bloodraven aka
the three-eyed raven who took the sword
with him when he took the black and then
later when he went north of the wall to
fully become the three-eyed raven so the
sword would have been with him in his
weirwood tree where they were training
bran to become the next three-eyed raven
but this whole early conflict earlier in
the timeline the war of the stepstones
basically serves as a precursor for the
battle of the gullet like i said which i
think is going to wind up being the big
wtf black water level episode for house
of the dragon early on but it was a
battle at sea with a bunch of ships so
that's why i make the blackwater
comparison but as the name implies the
battle took place here in the gullet to
blackwater bay between dragonstone
king's landing in driftmark so this area
was controlled by dragonstone for years
even before aegon the conqueror
conquered the seven kingdoms the
targaryen family used their position on
dragonstone here in driftmark which is
the seat of house velaryon the vassal
house of the targaryens to control trade
in this area making them a lot of money
during the dance of the dragon civil war
the blacks princess ronira's forces
controlled dragonstone and thereby house
valerian rhaenyra's first husband when
she was younger lenore velaryon was one
of the sons of lord corliss velaryon the
sea snake who was one of the leaders of
the forces of the blacks during the
dance of the dragons so what had
happened is that at the start of the
dance of the dragons house valerian led
by lord corliss valerian the sea snake
blockaded the gullet basically making it
way harder for the greens who controlled
king's landing to get supplies this
scene here is the flashback of his young
son lenar valerian walking on the beach
with a younger version of renera and her
three sons with him notice that he has
the white targaryen hair because the
valerians share blood with the
targaryens the reason why we know this
is a flashback not only because it's a
younger version of rhaenyra but it's
also because lenore here her first
husband wound up dying a long time
before the start of the actual dance of
the dragons which is gonna be the
present day of the show later during the
dance of the dragons when she's much
older this is the older version of her
character she eventually wound up
getting married to prince daemon
targaryen and having some more sons with
him fun fact too her oldest son with
laner here her first husband was named
joffrey so make all the joffrey game of
thrones jokes that you want but the
reason why they named him joffrey was
because he was named after layner's
favorite knight sir joffrey lonmuth it
wouldn't be a game of thrones related
show without a bunch of salacious rumors
about the different noble characters in
their past there was a salacious rumor
that her three children here with lehner
were actually secretly sired by a lover
that people believe that she had at
court growing up sir harwin strong he
was the captain of the city watch at
king's landing but the rumor was never
proven or disproven it was just one of
those rumors like people believing the
rumors that tyrion was secretly sired by
the mad king forcing himself on joanna
lannister if anybody remembers that from
the original show the mad king was known
to have coveted tywin lannister's wife
joanna lannister so there was a rumor
that he forced himself on her and that's
where tyrion came from but it was just a
rumor a really interesting theory but
one that i never believed to be true
there's all kinds of salacious rumors
like that that the people of westeros in
universe tell about the nobles so we'll
hear more rumors like this when episodes
get going next year brace yourself for
all the theories it's not game of
thrones unless you're secretly believed
to be the child of somebody else on the
show but the actual battle itself the
battle of the goal resulted in a ton of
casualties for both sides it was said
that after the battle ended in a very
bloody victory for the blacks just
barely considered a victory that lord
corliss velaryon who served as one of
the commanding generals of the blacks in
the battle since at the time he was head
of house valerian and controlled
driftmark it's claimed that he said if
this be victory i pray i never win
another because so many people died on
both sides of the battle so you have to
imagine a blackwater situation where a
bunch of people die on both sides it's
not just a very one-sided looking
victory the battle actually started when
princess rainier's oldest son from her
first husband laner valerian prince
jacaris decided that they would foster
his two younger half-brothers rhaenyra's
other children that she had after she
married prince damon targaryen he
decided that they would foster the young
princes in pentos over in the free
cities of essos until the dance of the
dragon civil war was over and his mother
princess rhaenyra has secured the iron
throne for herself if you remember
pentos was the city where illyrio lived
during the present day of the game of
thrones main series where varys and he
conspired to foster daenerys and viserys
targaryen until they could mount a
campaign to put them back on the iron
throne the formal name of their alliance
was the targaryen restoration that was
the whole goal but obviously it did not
go down the way they planned it would a
targaryen wound up winning the war just
not the one that they expected because
he was a secret targaryen
and it turns out he did not want the
iron throne as he said many many times
so the valerian ship that's going to
carry these young targaryen princes to
pentos to keep them safe during the
dance of the dragons award departs with
his escort but winds up encountering the
combined forces of the greens the other
faction in the dance of the dragon civil
war and that's when the actual battle of
the gullet begins so this giant fleet of
ships of the greens had been
orchestrated by sir otto hightower who's
being played by rhys ethan's on the
series this is a picture of him here if
you haven't seen him before he was
trying to break the blacks blockade of
this area which had cut them off at the
beginning of the dance of the dragons in
the blockade it just stretched on and on
for years at this point in order to do
that he orchestrated this plan to secure
an alliance with the triarchy the
combined forces of the free cities of
essos mir lis and tyrosh and used their
fleet to forcibly end the blockade they
sailed 90 of their warships across the
narrow sea into the gullet and that's
where they encountered the valerian
fleet that was carrying the young
princes to pentos so the initial battle
was super intense the princes had their
dragons with them too and then a bunch
of other dragons wound up joining the
fight so you have this giant dragon
fight going on while you have this fleet
of ships fighting each other so one
house of the dragon you have to imagine
this being like a combined version of
the game of thrones battle of blackwater
episode along with daenerys attacking
euron's fleet during game of thrones
season 8. both of those things happening
at the same time only with way way more
dragons fighting each other because at
this point in history the dragons had
not died off yet even though all the
dragons involved in the battle weren't
nearly as big as drogon for example
raniera's oldest son jakirus used his
dragon vermax to sweep the green ships
kind of like daenerys attacking euron's
fleet during the game of thrones season
8 but during this period like i said
vermax wasn't as large as drogon in the
triarchy fleet that he was trying to
burn down had experience fighting
dragons because earlier in the timeline
during earlier battles they had fought
damon targaryen and his dragon varaxis
during the war of the stepstones so they
knew how to fight dragons on their ships
the valerian fleet wound up losing a
third of its forces and remember they're
sworn to the blacks rainier's oldest son
from her first husband the sea snake's
son died along with his dragon vermax
one of her younger sons with daemon
targaryen aegon fled on his dragon storm
cloud and survived but his younger
brother viserys targaryen who was with
him he was one of the ones that was
going to pentos to hole up till the end
of the dance of the dragons war he wound
up being captured along with the dragon
egg that he had taken with him by the
triarchy forces and then they fostered
him with an ultra powerful rich family
in lis until years later when his family
learned that he was still alive
interestingly enough more than 40 45
years later this viserys wound up
becoming one of the kings of westeros
but he only sat on the iron throne for a
couple years and died at the age of 50.
but overall the battle was considered a
disaster by the triarchy whose remaining
forces limped home across the narrow sea
they didn't wind up breaking the
blockade so the battle was just
extremely costly for both sides so
obviously this is just a small preview
of a massive massive episode which is
going to have a ton a ton of wtf moments
if you spotted any other easter eggs
here in this first look just write them
below in the comments they're going to
be filming episodes for a little while
longer i believe so we'll probably
continue to get some more previews from
the set and maybe some early teaser
trailers before the end of the year
usually game of thrones released their
first official trailers for each season
in january and it seems like the house
of the dragons series is on the same
yearly episode schedule so my
expectation right now is that we'll get
the first big house of the dragon
trailer at the end of january or at
least by early february of course i'll
be doing episode videos for all the
episodes bonus videos just like i did
for the main game of thrones show
they'll be 10 episodes per season of the
house of the dragon series and like i
said it's probably gonna run between
five to seven seasons at least five
seasons but they haven't confirmed
absolutely what their plan is if you
have any big questions about what's
going on with the series or the
characters or just this part of the
timeline just leave them in the comments
below and i'll add them to my future
bonus videos i'll start doing more
videos for the show as we get closer to
the actual premiere in trailers dropping
but in related game of thrones news we
have both kit harington and richard
madden having a game of thrones reunion
in the marvel eternals movie you can
click here for my eternals trailer video
and learn all about kit harington's
character and click here for my other
new house of the dragon teaser trailer
and first look video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and i'll
see you in the next video